first of all I've never ever seen it
someone get a rockstar reception like
you just had is that something to get
used to it's something that um you never
get used to and you always I think I
don't I can't speak for others but I
always felt was maybe there you know in
you you want yeah I feel like somewhere
deep down I always felt there was some
sort of version of this in my destiny it
didn't manifest the way I thought I
didn't know the internet was going to
happen I didn't know I didn't know it
would happen in this I thought it would
be more on a pedestal for my business
accomplishments you could only see how
the Bill Gates's and the Rockefellers
and you know it wasn't this cool you
know business people are cool
entrepreneurs are cool now
so it's taken a little bit more more
young fandom than I anticipated but deep
down I always felt like I was gifted
something that over the course of my
life that would manifest I knew that I
know people liked me because I liked
them more that has really played out for
me and was it always my didn't do that
in business yes I since I was 13 I know
it's gonna be a visit or in Oblivion
before that but yes I always knew I was
a businessman hockey with baseball cards
lemonade like my whole life I did
nothing else not school not theater not
music not I was interested in nothing
but being a businessman purebred you
know like purebred like a pure purebred
entrepreneur but I also was the same kid
that was really nice to the most
disliked nerd kid in my school and the
most popular I always got along with
everybody
and I think that's playing out in social
media a lot of different types of people
can appreciate my message my attitude if
I can go up to the beginning
yeah well Wine Library TV yeah now it
seems like like a genius move yes I can
imagine it back into Davis the stupidest
thing what YouTube was only less than a
year old why was I wasting my time on it
I was building the business why am i
spending an hour making a show and then
four or five ten eleven hours
interacting with people in the comments
I'm supposed to be running a business I
just built this big business what are
you doing
into you know wasn't that I knew how
everything would play out but I knew
that it was
right I knew that people were going to
pay attention I knew the attention would
go there and I and I didn't know that I
would be such a showman I didn't know I
could do this but when I realized I
could very quickly I said okay this is
really interesting you know being funny
in class is one thing being able to do
it on a world stage and on-camera is
another thing but it happens and I'm
like okay you know I don't have any
entertainers or those kind of people my
family so never crossed my mind but when
I realize I had a little something and
then I became addicting you know builds
on itself you know that feeling build
makes me want to try harder to have more
of that feeling and it becomes a hamster
wheel I you had a lot of love for what
you did we on one Wine Library TV we
also had your fair amount of hate how do
you explain it I mean what people yeah
that's like yeah look down well you you
were dumbing down yes why yeah that's
very true the wine dentistry did not
like it at first when your pioneer you
have to be willing to take a lot of heat
you know the people that invent the
future are the ones who have the
self-confidence and the humility and the
ego and the and the intestinal fortitude
to deal with the pushback of the market
and it's something that has manifested
throughout your career I can think I can
say and also we have a thing I notice in
English the high tree sketches most win
hmm there is that what what has we I
love it is that maybe what we see and
that will be until I die yeah I will
always innovate I have too much
confidence to worry about what other
people think all the upside is being a
pioneer I want to be the highest tree
with the heaviest wind it is it may be
also fair to say that you move around in
a sector that has too much [ __ ] I
think everything has [ __ ] I feel
like the sectors that I just have to
jump in to where the sectors are jumped
in to but finance health care education
politics the auto industry and they all
have it because humans manifest [ __ ]
humans creep [ __ ] and politics to
protect their short-term interest
but how do you as a client and separate
the wheat from the chef you try you know
and sometimes we miss you swing and miss
and sometimes you get three home runs I
mean you know I think that's the talent
of a client I surely don't struggle with
it when I'm a client use intuition
you're like I told him you're not scared
of fire if you pick the wrong thing
you just move how have you been in
social media it seems it existed yeah
how would you see it change I think
people are starting to take it more
seriously especially with things like
brexit and Donald Trump I think people
are starting to understand this is not a
joke
this is not kicks and giggles this is
how humans communicate and so I've seen
it come from something nobody even knew
existed - early pioneers believing in it
- the investment community believing in
it - the media industry believing in it
- normal humans believing in it - the
establishment
believing in it - the universe believing
in it and also resonates in marketing I
suppose yeah and I think that um
marketing behind because there's a lot
of holding companies that make more
money selling the old stuff so when
you've got big companies that have
financial interest in the status quo
then you are then you have this
situation and you didn't only build a
brand with Wine Library you also been
built yourself into a brand I did
something that you leverage with with
vaynermedia I can get a link I can see
you're very smart - thank you you're
paying very close attention you're
exactly right on everything so far go
ahead um what I wonder is how much is
that n'sync to you as a person the
business quote well yeah it is it's
something that it's something that you
did with your business something that
you can transplant on through like big
brands yes yeah yes on all fronts yes
it's bigger because of my brand but
people have to remember I got a brand
because I built a business before I
became a brand so I was always going to
be a good business man anyway and so a
lot of our clients never knew who I was
when we got them yes I can transplant
into my people yes I can transplant at
the fans if you were listening to what
they were saying to me yes I can
transplant it to brands yes now can this
brand be a hundred percent me as
not but if I can give it to percent me
it's got a chance to be much bigger can
my employees be a hundred percent mean
no but if I give them 30 percent me it
could be much bigger can vaynermedia be
Gary Vaynerchuk absolutely not but if it
can be 90 percent of me then it can be
much bigger and so that's how I think
about it wow I would think it is a do
what makes you you is your sincere Eon
Don what you sell and and and what you
do when I look at brand and I always
know that they won once in the end to
sell me something yeah but if they make
the best water and if they make the
product so it's eco-friendly and if they
are better than the other waters and
they're confident well then that's me
you know I run businesses I'm not Mother
Teresa it's just that I think if you do
business with me you'll do better if you
then if you didn't as long as that
business thinks that their water is
better than everybody else's where they
get into trouble is if they know they're
getting their water from the same place
that somebody else is getting their
water and that's 80 cents in their
dollar 40 and they don't believe it
the thing that has always worked for me
as I believe pure like just you know I
think people can taste it it's why
they're attracted to it and I just think
the vaynermedia is the agency for every
single person that in the world that we
do digital look if you want to do
billboards that's not us if you want to
do activations at South by Southwest
live events it's not us yet you know so
I think I think that um if we stay in
our lane making digital work for you and
bringing you money I do think that's us
I saw you when you finish your speech
you find all the books I tell you take a
selfie or take a video of yourself and
say isolate it and I create yeah guys
yes it is that company competition yeah
Drive you as well ah the most it's the
part that you know being so competitive
unfortunately is my gift and my curse
it's my gift because it's helped me so
much it's my curse because it's the
North Star that manifests the ego and
the bravado that for some people is a
turn-off but I know that I'm coming from
a good place I want to beat these two
guys but I don't want them to fail
I want me just want to be that I just
want to be better and I think a lot of
people want people to fail
and they're not very good and by killing
everybody else that they're the only
ones left well you've got me to me I
want everybody to play I just want to
rise above everyone as in your speech or
in the Q&A section you talk a bit about
your investment you said that well if
you are involved from the beginning and
you're involved organically and you
build the business yourself if I'm the
operator you're it's a home run
yeah but you also have quite a track
record in investing something that you
don't have what I refer to as a middle
so when I'm the operator it's a home run
when I've invested and have nothing to
do with the business I've done extremely
well home runs Facebook Twitter it's the
middle when it's kind of my business and
I'm kind of supposed to be involved but
I'm not the decision-maker that was
funky for me in 2009 to 13 now I've done
it better I had a company called brave
consulting firm they just sold to Turner
when I was involved that way I've got a
company called resi a restaurant open
table computer it's doing extremely well
I learned a lot and milling and made
promises upfront that were different
used my time and my strategies more
effectively I've learned from failing
thank you so much yeah thank you yeah
real pleasure I wish you well
[Music]